- [Narrator] Haruo Nakajima is arguably
the most famous Japanese
actor of all time.
But you've probably never seen his face.
That's because Nakajima
was inside the body
of a giant monster that destroyed Tokyo.
(dramatic music)
(Godzilla roaring)
- [Narrator] Shortly after
the end of World War II,
Haruo Nakajima went to
work for the movie studio
Toho Pictures in Tokyo, Japan
to pursue his dream of becoming an actor.
He got his start as a
stuntman in Samurai films
such as Seven Samurai, which
were all the rage at the time.
- [Narrator] But it was on the
set of a World War II film,
Eagle of the Pacific, where
Nakajima caught the eye
of the director, Ishiro Honda.
- [Narrator] Nakajima met with
Honda and the production team
for this new, untitled monster movie,
but no one really had any
direction for his role
as the monster, so he
started doing research.
- [Narrator] On top of that,
creating the creature's suit
was no easy task, especially
in post-war Japan.
- [Narrator] After six
grueling months of shooting,
the first Godzilla movie was
released in Japan in 1954.
No one had any idea how
it would be received.
- [Narrator] Godzilla wound
up becoming one of Japan's
most ubiquitous cultural milestones,
both for its achievements in filmmaking
and its message of the
dangers of atomic weapons.
And Nakajima?
He put on the monster
suit for 11 more movies.
And at 87 years old, it
is the pride of his life.
(Godzilla roaring)